joining me right here on the rich eisen
show is a man who i mentioned about a
super bowl in houston
this is where i met him i met him in
houston i think
chris i've told you the story about
meeting this guy right eli manning i've
told you the story
he will definitely remember i know this
for a fact because that was the night
his dad made me
an unofficial fourth manning
that happened okay and he's here on
behalf of yahoo sports
he is eli manning how are you eli
i'm doing great rich how are you you
remember that night right you're a
brother so i call you brother now
did i call you brother well i don't know
i don't know if i'm breaking you
any news to you but when your dad texts
me he does refer to me as
son that's a fact that happens
whenever he texts me so there's that
you're welcome you're welcome you know i
appreciate it welcome to any family
gatherings we
we can't have any now but no not a while
you know send me the link you know i'll
hop on i'll hop on
i will i will 100 how are you doing
what's going on with you
eli i'm i'm doing well i'm doing well
just uh
yeah just kind of you know getting used
to this retirement thing and
and you know finding out my routine and
how to spend my days
and uh it's kind of just one one thing a
day you know like today i was talking
with you on the phone
tomorrow dentist next day i haven't
decided yet
i got some time to figure out what the
what my one thing to accomplish
on wednesday is gonna be okay so it's a
cleaning tomorrow eli cleaning we go
we're looking what do what do we got
tomorrow we got just x-rays yeah
yeah just cleaning okay kind of a
standard yeah just yeah just to just
check out nothing hopefully nothing
nothing serious just kind of my
my uh i kind of miss i missed the last
one
because because of colvin and everything
and so i'm kind of a little behind a
little a little behind so i gotta just
get back in there and
hopefully just yeah just a cleaning okay
good because i was gonna basically say
then at least this interview is not
about pulling teeth
so you know at least there's nothing to
equate those two things together
you know things just could be straight
up me chatting with you i mean
but it has to be interesting to you to
wake up on a monday and not feel any
aches and pains right i mean that's got
to be a nice
improvement yeah i mean it is i mean
that's that's kind of the
the difference and you know this is it's
it's new to me
watching the giants uh as a fan you know
i i never
i didn't grow up watching the giants as
a fan of the last
you know 16 years right i was playing i
wasn't i never
sat there and watched watched you know
watch the giants play on tv and so
um it's it's new and you know you find
yourself i'm still you know i'm rooting
for them i'm reformed hard because
i have you know great friends on that
team still and sterling shepard and evan
ingram and saquon and daniel jones and
you know the bearer family the pitch
family and they're close
close friends and and you know i feel
for them when they have these losses and
i'm going through it
and i want them to win yet on you know
monday morning you know physically i
feel a lot better and mentally
it's not as draining i'm not dreading
the week i'm not
dreading i'm going into a meeting and
you know
you know thinking about this you know
this terrible throw i made and
and uh not having that not having to
deal with the losses the losses
um you know got tougher and tougher to
deal with and to overcome and so i just
got tired of it and
um so it's been a you know and i was
ready i was ready to be done playing in
february when i when i retired and i
knew
i was done playing football and and you
know i still have those same feelings i
mean
i'm happy where i am you know sitting
sitting on
on on the couch and and watching these
games
uh on sunday no i know eli i mean and
you're watching you know philip
is now in indianapolis big ben the other
quarterback
with whom you are associated because of
your draft class is performing what he's
doing in pittsburgh right now is there
any part of you that does
say you know what if circumstances could
have been x y and z i'd
love to still be out there right now
no i think i think i was i was done you
know i just i had i had my run i had my
time
i enjoyed it i have such you know great
memories and that's
the great thing about you know football
and in
16 years is that you know i i you know
when i think about the time i i think
about the positive stuff i think about
you know the celebrations in the locker
room the plane ride homes the training
camps with my buddies the locker room
uh you know you know celebrating you
know wins
in the stadium with crowds and and you
know the energy
and uh that that's what i feel but uh
you know but you know on monday mornings
when i wake up
and and the giants you know kind of
today after a loss i'm
also grateful i'm not going into the
facility today
and uh and having that plane ride home
uh from chicago last night after lost
those
those things uh can wear wear on you and
uh
and i'm you know and i yeah i i you know
i see big ben playing and they're
they're winning
i see you know uh phil changing teams
and going to a new organization which i
would have
done last year you know this year if i
wanted to play and uh
you know i'm good where i am i made i
made that decision in february i'm not
going to look back i'm not going to
second guess
i wasn't working out for football and
hoping you know thinking there may be a
comeback as someone called i i was i was
uh
i had had enough and and uh grateful for
my time but you know looking forward to
uh to this new this new way of life eli
manning here on the rich eisen show
courtesy of yahoo which we'll get to in
a second
and um i don't know you might be um
on a tour of some sort calling around i
don't know if you heard but saquon
barkley it is official
did in fact suffer an acl injury in
chicago yesterday he has done for the
year
you saw what he went through last year
with his ankle
i just want to give me your thoughts on
such a a difficult piece of news to hear
about saquon
eli yeah yeah it's just you know that's
tough and i feel
for saquon individually as a person and
injuries in this game are tough and
running backs and
you know to have a knee injury and no
you know he's gonna
do everything it takes to rehab and get
back but just to have a
a season a season lost um
is tough to swallow so you know i just i
feel for him
uh as a as a person um you know just
having to go through that i know he's
worked hard and done everything to try
to have a big year
and um and so just you know
my thoughts and prayers are with them
and i'll reach out to them
uh later on but um you know that's just
uh unfortunately that's a little bit of
the game of football and
now the team's gonna have to rally and
they're gonna be devastated
a little bit because he's a captain and
a leader and
and supposed to be kind of um carrying
this team on his back a little bit
and other guys don't have to step up and
and you know
that's just you know the way football
goes and guys you know
the team's have to rally and and uh and
you know make some make some adjustments
and get back and
and you know play a little play better
and start winning some football games
yeah they almost pulled it out yesterday
i mean that that was impressive to me
you know they all because they had to
know they had i'm just seeing his
reaction carted off they had to know
this was
most likely it from that
yeah and yeah and i think you know i
think they they did they rallied had
a couple nice drives there in the fourth
quarter i was watching it
with my daughter we were celebrating we
saw the flag thrown on the last play we
were thinking of
defensive past interference and we're
getting excited
and they uh you know saw the call as
offensive so
um you know tough tough to to swallow
that one where you're you know
you're fighting and making a little
rally and just come up a little bit
a little bit short and uh and then you
know probably know that you're
uh you know your star players uh injured
and
not not looking not looking good for the
outcome of that but
you know um you know i think you know
the only thing that heals this is
is victories the only thing that can
help uh
kind of get get past it and start moving
forward is to get back on the
on the practice field have great weeks
of preparation and go compete
and uh and see if you can get a win and
that can
that can solve a lot of issues and solve
a lot of problems and
and give you some relief for a little
bit eli manning here on the rich eisen
show
um tell me about the yahoo sports mobile
app that you're talking about right here
eli what do you got for me
on this front yeah it's a new feature
it's a new feature
uh rich it'd be it'd be good for for us
it's called watch
together okay it basically uh enables
nfl fans to video chat on their phone
with friends
while watching uh live football games
and you can watch the
the live local or the primetime games
and you just download the yahoo sports
app
and uh you get to invite three friends
okay
uh to watch the game together so you
know i think you know kind of when you
have these
this time where most stadiums uh are
having no fans or some have limited fans
if you're used to going to the games and
and having that experience of
celebrating and watching the games with
your family or with your friends and now
you can't do that you can't have these
gatherings and
um this is a way for you to kind of
create that experience and you know if
you have your
uh you know if you have your buddies
that you know go the game now you can
still
you know get to get the yahoo sports app
it's free
you get to watch the games for free and
get to invite them and so you still get
to cheer the touchdowns and celebrate
the victories and
and you're not just on the couch doing
it you know by yourself you're with your
buddies or with your
family who you're used to watching these
games with so i think a pretty natural
selection you know would be my brothers
peyton cooper
and rich isaac uh you know us watching
the game on a sunday
you know and together would be would be
ideal
i think so too i agree sorry arch um
it's
that's that's the four right there you
payton cupper and me
i mean so um now
uh when was the last time you did watch
a football game with peyton just
you and him when was the last time that
happened eli
you know i was i was thinking about that
earlier just kind of
um yeah when's the last time
you know would have been like you know
my brothers peyton coop and my dad
you know sitting on sitting at home
watching watching a football game
i think it's got to be 30 years ago
at least i can't think of a time where
we would have been
together we've been at some super bowls
together you know
but peyton was playing or i was playing
right and you know i think
you know it goes back to probably when
when you know coop and paint were in
high school at some point
and i was 10 years old and watching you
know watching the saints game or
watching a sunday night game or
something on on the on the couch and
uh you know it's probably it's been it's
been a long
a long time and so you know this this
kind of gives us that opportunity
to do that again i don't know who we're
going to watch though i kind of want to
watch the giants you know peyton's going
to watch the colts or
the broncos koopie you know he wants to
watch canadian football i think
you know my dad wants to watch the
saints so right um
you know it'd be hard to kind of figure
out who to which game to watch or
and how we kind of get that situated i
know again if it's something that you
haven't done with your brothers in so
long why wouldn't you want me involved
in this eli you know
why wouldn't you want me there to i know
just be part of that warm and fuzzy
family moment
um when when you see the when you see
when you see the video of you throwing
to tyree
okay what do you think of when you see
that
when you see that whenever you sit down
and see what do you say
um what do you see i just smile i just
i'm just
thankful thankful for david tyree man
there's not a a better person
and and a guy who just uh
you know who had the worst week of
practice in the history of
of all practices on that friday and
dropped every pass and
you know thought he was going to be the
starting receiver and then flexco you
know comes back and plays that game and
then
sure enough in the game david tyree has
a touchdown catch
and then makes the catch you know it's
rodney harrison hanging all over them
um you know bob pop is giving the call
saying you know he's got a wide open
receiver
you know and i guess that's wide open in
the nfl and
you know david tyree just the will
desire was there and just
catching it off the helmet just what a
what unbelievable story and
uh you know never get tired of watching
that play all right
chris brockman my honor compadre here
what do you tell him go ahead tell him
what you say every time now that he's
here you can say it to his face go ahead
chris
well usually i say it to sean o'hara
because shawn is here right i mean there
were 14 different holdings on this is
holding
eli what do you say to that when he says
[Laughter]
all four players you know they kind of
just block them off you know i think
yeah it's probably holding if the guy's
holding me
you know like a defense player is
holding me i think you're allowed to do
whatever you want
right to the uh to the you know to the
hash rusher at that point
if i'm in the grass they could just grab
them also and pull them off it's kind of
a
it's kind of free range at that point at
that moment i agree you
chris you see holding eli sees grasping
that's what he sees i see the greatest
play ever that's right there's a giant
i was sitting right there i was there in
the building
that's it all right eli you take care of
yourself all right
say uh say hi to say hi to dad say hi to
your brothers
say hi to everybody okay and i'll see
our brother yeah i'll see your brother
our brothers yes say hi to our brothers
i'll see you at thanksgiving okay
we'll see you then i'll say thanksgiving
i look forward to it you're garbage
besties
you got a man that's eli manning at eli
manning on twitter that he has joined
he's my bro hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here